tengo problemas soy matemático
los matemáticos tenemos problemas muchos
problemas para hacer que los demás
también tenéis problemas pero es que los
matemáticos nos gustan los problemas
un buen problema es un regalo para un
matemático un problema excelente es un
regalo para toda la comunidad matemática
y un problema clásico es un regalo yo
creo para toda la humanidad y por qué
bueno pues voy a contar una historia de
un problema su solución y un par de
mensajes que traigo de parte de los
matemáticos
para los mortales
hace un tiempo hace unos meses coloque
en el tablón de anuncios del
departamento de matemáticas donde yo
trabajo con lo que un problema un
problema este problema
se trata de saber si el perímetro de ese
cuadrado es mayor o menor que la
longitud de la circunferencia de esa
circunferencia pensadlo mirad un poco el
problema no es difícil no es un problema
difícil
veo gente inquieta como con ganas de
llorar yo fui a la solución no
preocuparse si alguien no la quiere oír
esto es un auto spoiler de mi misma
charla os voy a dar la solución
para solucionar este problema yo pedí a
la gente que me enviara sus soluciones
que cualquiera que tuviera resolución
que me hiciera llegar que me hiciera
llegar la solución que tuviera fuera más
sencilla más compleja a la que quisiera
y ya esta es la que dice yo yo también
las soluciones
supongamos mirad que tenemos ahí podemos
trazar desde el centro de la
circunferencia ahora empiezan las mates
y cuidado la gente impresionable
empiezan las mates desde el centro de la
circunferencia podemos trazar una línea
a la esquina o al punto medio de ese
cuadrado supongamos que el radio de la
circunferencia es 1 da igual para este
problema no es relevante entonces en ese
cuadrado ese es el lado en ese triángulo
el lado mide 1 es el lado mide 1 este
otro como es la mitad del lado del
cuadrado mide l medios y este otro mide
l menos 1 porque el 1 bueno pues porque
si esto es 1 que también es un radio
verdad como es otro radio es 1 y todo
este cuadrado es l pues lo que le falta
al 1 pase dl pues es l menos 1 y ya está
tenemos ahí un triángulo un triángulo
rectángulo con su hipotenusa y sus
catetos las palabras hipotenusa y
catetos solo se usan para una cosa en la
vida
en toda vuestra vida solo los usamos
para una cosa extrema pitágoras fuera de
ahí esas palabras no existen no las
usamos jamás no pues es el momento
vuestro momento de gloria decir yo me sé
extrema pitágoras el cuadrado de la
hipotenusa es igual a la suma de los
cuadrados de los catetos pues esta es la
magia de pitágoras que permite traducir
esas líneas la geometría el círculo el
triángulo en ecuaciones en álgebra con
eso podemos trabajar y haciendo esas
manipulaciones que los matemáticos
hacemos con el álgebra sacar
conclusiones de la geometría de las
líneas entonces uno pone la ecuación que
nos da el teorema de pitágoras lo de los
cuadrados ahí la tenéis hace esas
manipulaciones que hacemos los
matemáticos con las cuentas y llega a
que el lado del cuadrado es 8 quintos
ocho quintos muy bien casa gusto dice
sus ocho quintos entonces el perímetro
es cuatro veces eso 32 quintos y en la
longitud de la circunferencia es 2 pi
vale y que el más grande 32 quintos o 2
pi pues un poco [ __ ] la calculadora no
pero también podemos dividir y
deportividad está entre 2 16 quintos por
un lado y por el otro y 16 quintos
cuánto es 16 106 3 con 2 que todo el
mundo sabemos que es más grande que p
por qué pies 3.14 y pico no así que
queridos amigos acaba tu preocupación
ya podéis relajarnos relajar demasiado
pero ya podéis relajar os podéis dejar
de llorar el perímetro del cuadrado es
mayor que la circunferencia y uno se
siente aliviado se siente bien vuelve a
dormir por las noches bueno pues este
este es el problema está la solución yo
recibí para este problema 25 soluciones
de 25 personas me escribieron profesores
compañeros de la universidad alumnos
hijos de algunos compañeros todos me
escribieron con soluciones de problema
recibí 25 soluciones distintas de las
cuales 11 eran esencialmente diferentes
utilizaban matemáticas distintas había
quien utilizó matemáticas antiguas
potencias de un punto con respecto a la
circunferencia semejanza de triángulos
áreas de triángulos había gente que
utilizaban matemáticas más modernas
utilizaron coordenadas cartesianas la
ecuación de la circunferencia hubo
incluso quien utilizó números complejos
para resolver este problema matemáticas
todavía más modernas pero todas las
soluciones todas todas tenían en común
que al final decir dependían de 32 es
mayor que pi
bueno pues con todo esto con todas estas
matemáticas decidí armar una charla en
mi universidad y contarle a la gente de
mi departamento de a todo el que
quisiera todas estas soluciones todas
las diferentes maneras de solucionar
este problema me parecía bonito porque
se habían dado muchísimas soluciones
diferentes cada cual según su bagaje
según sus preferencias incluso podríamos
decir según su personalidad había
solucionado ese problema sí que parecía
bonito tema para una charla arme una
charla y entonces en mi facultad allí en
la universidad de la rioja prepare esta
charla vino gente de los profesores los
que habían mandado soluciones vinieron
alumnos vinieron profesores de los
institutos vino mi profesor del
instituto el que me dio a mí matemáticas
con el que yo di mis primeros pasos en
las matemáticas de verdad que seguro que
estaría orgulloso el hombre porque de
aquel chaval que conoció él con 15 años
al que introdujo las matemáticas pues
míralo ahora dando charlas en la
universidad e investigando un doctor en
matemáticas seguro de estar orgulloso
para el caso que la charla fue bien pues
muy bien estuvo muy entretenida
y
al final todos discutiendo la
descripción fue interesante estuvimos
discutiendo si no se podría solucionar
ese problema sin saber cuánto vale pi
sin saber qué pie es más pequeño que 3
con 2 sin saber si vale 3 o 4 15-16 una
solución puramente geométrica que
solamente explorará las relaciones entre
ese cuadrado y esa circunferencia lo
habíamos hablado con algunos compañeros
antes de esa charla pero también lo
hablamos allí y la verdad que no lo
conseguimos pero bueno diríamos que
sería una bonita soluciones
tres días más tarde recibí un correo
electrónico
con una respuesta a ese problema una
solución que no usaba el valor de pi que
solamente usaba las relaciones entre el
cuadrado y la circunferencia una
solución puramente geométrica
me la mandó mi profesor del instituto
tantos años después y tantas matemáticas
después él sigue siendo mi maestro él
sigue siendo mi profesor él me sigue
enseñando
hay maestros que lo son para toda la
vida y yo tengo la suerte de haber
conocido a uno yo creo que todos podemos
ser maestros para toda la vida solo hace
falta que estemos dispuestos a aprender
siempre porque la educación es muchas
cosas enseñar es muchas cosas pero desde
luego si hay una cosa que desee enseñar
es compartir lo aprendido y si uno no
está dispuesto a seguir aprendiendo toda
la vida no podrá ser un maestro toda la
vida así que para eso os traigo estos
dos mensajes que os decía de parte de
los matemáticos para vosotros son dos
mensajes muy obvios son mensajes que
todos conocemos lo que pasa que a veces
se nos olvidan y los matemáticos por
nuestra profesión tratamos con ellos
todos los días uno
un problema es siempre una oportunidad
para aprender siempre siempre no solo
los problemas matemáticos que son
ejercicios para aprender matemáticas
todo el problema es una oportunidad para
aprender van a venir los problemas
seguro eso es inevitable pero uno puede
decidir si aprende de ellos o no así que
lo primero que os traigo de parte de los
matemáticos es una un problema es una
oportunidad para aprender y lo segundo
es que para un problema para alcanzar la
solución a un problema hay muchas formas
diferentes muchas formas distintas
probablemente van a depender de tu
bagaje van a depender de tus
preferencias incluso de tu personalidad
si eso pasa para un problema matemático
como no va a pasar para los otros
problemas así que hay muchas formas es
el segundo mensaje hay muchas formas de
llegar a la solución de un problema yo
creo que ahora después de estos
minutitos os hacéis un poquito mejor
idea de por qué a los matemáticos no os
gustan tanto los problemas aunque no sea
más que un problema de saber si un
cuadrado es más o menos grande el
perímetro de una circunferencia así que
seguimos aprendiendo
felices problemas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]